-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
you're doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The White House today
announced new initiatives
to combat junk fees.
Sounds like somebody
tried to see Frankie Valli.
"Convenience fee?
Jill, get Janet Yellen
on the phone."
House Republicans
today nominated Majority
Leader Steve Scalise
to be the next speaker,
while next week's Speaker
is still anyone's guess.
[ Laughter ]
Federal prosecutors accused
Republican Congressman
Jorge Santos
yesterday of stealing campaign
donors' identities.
But if you donated money
to Jorge Santos,
you're probably looking for
a new identity anyway.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Federal prosecutors
filed 23 charges
against Republican Congressman
Jorge Santos,
including two counts
of aggravated identity theft,
two counts of wire fraud
and numerous counts of trying
to make this look a thing.
[ Laughter ]
A group of House Republicans
who call themselves
Okay for Only Kevin are
reportedly planning to nominate
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
for the speakership.
Unfortunately, a group
that calls themselves
F-K won't let them.
[ Laughter ]
At a campaign rally earlier
this week, former president
Trump said that he believes
former president Barack Obama
is in control
of the White House.
Yeah, right. You wish.
And also we wish.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Vice President Kamala Harris
said that she loves her job,
though it was a little
concerning
that she said it in response
to every single question.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the super PAC affiliated
with Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
raised $11 million
in the 24 hours
after he announced
he was running for president
as an independent.
Wow. Kennedy hasn't made
millions of dollars that fast
since the day he was born.
[ Laughter ]
When asked to identify him
yesterday in court,
disgraced FTX CEO
Sam Bankman-Fried's
ex-girlfriend reportedly
took nearly 30 seconds
to recognize him because he
finally tried conditioner.
[ Laughter ]
A library in Scotland
recently received a book
that was nearly
50 years overdue.
The person would
have returned it sooner,
but they were waiting
for a sunny day.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we'll [bleep] burn
Scottish weather.
[ Laughter ]
If not this week, when?
According to a new report,
Apple CEO Tim Cook
starts his day by reading
hundreds of customer
feedback e-mails
before going to the gym.
Oh, wow. Sounds like Tim Cook
and I have something in common.
We both like to lie.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a cruise ship
in the Pacific Ocean
recently rescued a naked man
who was clinging
to a capsized boat.
The man was able
to get a hot meal,
some clean clothes and COVID.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.